one of the things you work on and write
about is dark matter we can't see it but
there's a lot of it in the
universe uh you also end one of your
books with a Beatles song quote got to
be good-looking cuz he's so hard to
see what is dark matter how should we
think about it given that we can't see
it how should we visualize it in our
Mind's Eye I think one of the really
important things that physics teaches
you is just our limit ations but also
our abilities so the fact that we can
deduce the existence of something that
we don't directly see is really a
tribute to people that we can do that
but it's also something that tells you
you can't overly rely on your direct
senses if you just relied on just what
you see directly you would miss so much
of what's happening in the world and we
can generalize this but we're just for
now to focus on dark matter it's
something we know is there and it's not
not just one way we know it's there in
my book dark matter and the dinosaurs I
talk about the many different ways you
know this eight or nine that we we
deduce not just the existence of dark
matter but how much how much is there
and they all agree now how do we know
it's there because of its
gravitational force and individually a
particle doesn't have such a big
gravitational force in fact gravity is
an extremely weak force compared to
other forces we know about in nature but
there's a lot of Dark Matter out there
it carries a lot of energy five times
the amount of energy as the matter we
know that's in atoms Etc so you can ask
how should we think about it well it's
just another form of matter that doesn't
interact with light or at least as far
as we know so it interacts
gravitationally it clumps it forms
galaxies but it doesn't interact with
light which means we just don't see it
and most of our detection before
gravitational wave detectors we only saw
things because of their interactions
with light in some sense so in theory it
it behaves just like any other matter
just it just doesn't interact with light
so when we say it interacts just like
any other form of matter we have to be
careful um because gravitationally it
interacts like other forms of matter but
it doesn't experience electromagnetism
which is why it has a different
distribution so in our galaxy it's
roughly
spherical unless it has its own
interactions that's another story but we
we know that it's roughly spherical um
whereas ordinary matter can radiate and
clumps into a disc and that's why we see
the Milky Way desk so on large scales in
some sense yes all the matter is similar
in some sense in fact dark matter is in
some sense more important because it can
collapse more readily than ordinary
matter because ordinary
matter has has radiative forces which
makes it hard to collapse on small
scales so actually it's dark matter that
sort of drives um Galaxy formation and
then ordinary matter kind of comes along
with it um and there's also just more of
it and because there's more of it it can
start collapsing sooner that is to say
the energy density in Dark Matter
dominates over radiation earlier than
you would if you just had ordinary
matter so it's part of the story of the
origin of a Galaxy part of the story of
the end of the Galaxy and part of the
story of all the various interactions
through exactly I mean in my book make
kind of sort of jokes about you know
it's like when we think about a building
we think about the architect we think
about you know the high level but we
forget about all the workers that did
all the grunt work and in fact Dark
Matter was really important in the
formation of our universe and we forget
that sometimes that's a a metaphor on
top of a metaphor
okay the the the unheard voices that do
the actual work okay exactly no but it
is a metaphor but it also captures
something because the fact is we don't d
directly see it so we forget it's there
or we don't understand it's there or we
think it's not the fact that we don't
see it makes it no less legitimate it
just means that we have challenges in
order to find out exactly what it is
yeah but the things we cannot see that
nevertheless have uh gravitational
interaction with the things we can't see
is at the uh
Layman level is just mindblowing you
know it is and isn't because I think
what it's teaching us is that we're
human the universe is what it is and
we're trying to interact with that
universe and and discover what it is
we've discovered amazing things in fact
I would say it's more surprising that
the mount the matter that we know about
is constitutes as big a fraction of the
universe as it does I mean we're limited
we're human and the fact that we see 5%
of the energy dens of the Universe um
you know about one six of the energy
density in matter that's kind of
remarkable I mean why should that be
there could be anything out anything
could be out there yet the universe that
we see is a significant fraction yeah
but a lot of our intuition I think
operates using visualizations in the
mind that's absolutely true and it's
certainly writing books I realized also
how many of our words are based on how
we see the world um and that's true and
that's actually one of the Fantastic
things about physics is that it teaches
you how to go beyond your immediate
intuition to develop intuitions that
apply at different distances different
scales different ways of thinking about
things yeah how do you anthropomorphize
dark matter how I just did I think I
made it the grun work workers oh yeah
that's good yeah you did that's why he
get paid the big bucks with the and
write the great books okay so um you
also write in that book
about uh dark matter matter having to do
something with the extinction events the
extinction of the dinosaur SCE um which
is kind of a
fascinating presentation of how
everything is connected so I guess the
disturbances
from the dark matter they create
gravitational disturbances in the OR
Cloud at the edge of our solar system
and then that increases the rate of
asteroids hitting Earth so I want to be
really clear this was a speculative
Theory I love it though I mean and I
liked it too and um and we still don't
know for sure but we can what we liked
about it so let me take a step back so
we usually assume that dark matter is
what we being physicists that just one
thing it's just basically non
interacting in on aside from gravity or
very weakly interacting matter um but
again we have to get outside this
mindset of just humans and ask what else
could be there and so what we suggested
is that there's a fraction of dark
matter not all the dark matter
but some of the Dark Matter maybe it has
interactions of its own just the same
way in in our universe we have lots of
different types of matter we have nuclei
we have electrons we have M we have
forces um we have lots of it's it's not
a simple model the standard model but
but it does have some basic ingredients
so maybe Dark Matter also has some
interesting um structure to it so maybe
there's some small fraction and the
interesting thing is that if some of the
Dark Matter does radiate and you know I
like to call it dark light because it's
light that we don't see but Dark Matter
would see it could radiate that and then
it could perhaps collapse into a disc
the same way ordinary matter collapsed
in into the Milky Way disc so it's not
all the dark matter it's a fraction but
it could conceivably be a very thin disc
of Dark Matter thin dense disc of dark
matter and so then the question is do
these exist and people have done studies
now to think about whether they can find
them I mean it's an interesting Target
it's something you can measure by
measuring the positions and velocities
of stars you can find out what the
structure of them of the Milky Way is um
but the fun proposal was that the solar
system orbits around the Galaxy and as
it does so it goes a little bit up and
down kind of like horses on a Carousel
and the suggestion was every time it
goes through you have an enhanced
probability that you would dislodge
something from the edge of the solar
system and something called the or Cloud
so the idea was that at those times
you're more likely to have these
cataclysmic events such as the amazing
one that actually caused the last
Extinction that we know of for sure it
wasn't so amazing for the dinosaurs or
for two-thirds of the species on the
planet yeah but it get amazing for
humans wouldn't be what really is
amazing I mean I I do I mean I talk
about this in dark matter in the
dinosaurs I it's just an amazing
scientific story because it really is
one of the real stories that combine
together different fields of science
geologist at the time or you know people
thought that things happened slowly and
this would be a cataclysmic event and
also I have to say you know if you if
you think about it it sounds like a
story like a 5-year-old would make up
maybe the dinosaurs were killed by some
big rock that came and hit the Earth but
then there really was a scientific story
behind it and that's also why I like the
dark disc because there's a scientific
story behind it so as farfetched as in
might zound you can actually go and look
for the experimental consequences or the
observational consequences to test
whether it's true I wish you could know
like high resolution details of where
that asteroid came from like where in
the OR Cloud why it happened is it in
fact because of dark matter it's like
the full tracing back to the origin of
the universe CU it humans seem to be
somewhat special but just it seems like
so many fascinating events at all scales
at all scales of physics had to happen
for so I'm really really glad you
mentioned that because actually that was
one of the main points of my book dark
matter in the dinosaurs one of the
reasons I wrote it was because I really
think we are abusing the planet we're
changing the planet way too quickly and
just like anything else when you alter
things it's good to think about the
history of what it took to get here and
it and as you point out it took many
operations on many different scales you
know we had to have the formation of of
structure the formation of galaxies the
formation of the solar system the
formation of our planet the formation of
humans I mean there's so many steps that
go into this and humans in some part
were the result of the fact that this
big object hit the earth made the
dinosaurs go extinct and mammals
developed I mean it is an incredible
story
and yes something else might come of it
but it won't be us if we mess with it
too much but it is an a grand scale
Earth is a pretty resilient
system uh C can you just clarify just
fascinating uh the shape of things so
the shape of the Milky Ways of the
observable stuff is mostly
flat and you said Dark Matter tends to
be spherical but a subset of that might
be a flat disc so you wanted to hear
about the shape of things yes yes please
so structure formed early on and now our
structure that we live in is so we know
about the Milky Way galaxy so the Milky
Way galaxy has the dis you can see in a
dry dark place that's where stars and
light is
but you can also measure in some ways
the dark matter and we believe that dark
matter is more or less spherically
distributed um and like we said there's
a lot of it not necessarily in the dis
but just because it's a sphere there's a
lot of it sitting there and the reason
it doesn't collapse as far as we know is
that it doesn't really it can't radiate
the same way so because it can radiate
ordinary matter collapses and it's
actually because of conservation of
angular momentum it be it stays at disk
and it doesn't just collapse to the
center so our suggestion was that maybe
there are some components of dark matter
that also rate it like I said that's far
from proven people have looked for a
disc they see some evidence of some
discs of certain densities but I see
these are all questions that are worth
asking basically if we can figure it out
from existing measurements why not try
Okay so there's not all Dark Matters
made the same this well that's a
possibility we actually don't know what
dark matter is in the first place we
don't know what most of it is we don't
know what a fraction is I mean it's hard
to measure why is it hard to measure for
exactly the reason you said earlier we
don't see it so we want to think of
possibilities for what it can be if
especially if those give rise to some of
observational consequences I mean it's
it's a tough game because it's not
something that's just there for the
taking you have to think about what it
could be and how you might find it and
the way you detect it is gravitational
effects on things we can see that would
be the way you detect the type of Dark
Matter I've been talking about people
have suggestions for other forms of dark
matter they could be particles called
axons they could be other types of
particles and then there are different
ways of detecting it I mean the most
popular candidate for Dark Matter
probably until pretty recently because
they haven't found it is something
called wimps weekly interacting mass of
particles um particles that have mass
about the same as the higs boson Mass um
and it turns out then you would get
about the right density of dark matter
but then people really like that of
course because it is connected to the
standard model the particles that we
know about and if it's connected to that
we have a better chance of actually
seeing it fortunately or unfortunately
it's also a better chance that you can
rule it out because you can look for it
and so far no one has found it we're
still looking for it is that one of the
hopes of the large hydron collider that
was originally one of the hopes of large
hydron collider I'd say at this point it
would be very unlikely given what
they've already accomplished um but
there are these um underground detectors
Xenon detectors that look for Dark
Matter coming in and they they are going
to try to achieve a much stronger bound
than it exists today just uh take that
tangent Looking Back Now what's the
biggest to you
Insight uh to humanity that the LHC has
been able to provide it's interesting
it's both um a major victory
um the Hig bosone was proposed 50 years
ago and it was discovered the Hig
mechanism seemed to be the only way to
explain elementary particle masses and
it was right so on the one hand it was a
major victory on the other hand I've
been in physics long enough to know it
was also a cautionary Tale in some sense
because um at the time I started out in
physics we had some proposed something
in the United States called the super
conducting super collider a lot of
physicists I'll say particularly in
Europe but I'd say a lot of physicists
were saying when that the large hyron
collider would have the energy reach
necessary to discover what underlies the
standard model we don't want to just
discover the St all we want to know what
the next step is and I think here um
people were more cautious about that
they wanted to have a more comprehensive
search that could get to higher energies
more events so that we could you know we
could really more definitively rule it
out but in that case many people thought
they knew what would be there it
happened to be a theory called super
symmetry so a lot of physicists thought
it would be super symmetry I mean it's
one of the many factors I think that
went into the fact that the large hron
collider became the only machine in town
and um the superc conducting super
collider would have just been a much if
it really had achieved what it was
supposed to would have been a much more
robust test of of the space so so I'd
say for Humanity it's both a tribute to
the ability of Discovery and the ability
of really believing in things so that
they have the confidence to go look for
them but it's also a cautionary tale
that you don't want to you know
assume things before they've been
actually found so you want to do things
in you know you you want to believe in
your theories but you also want to
question them at the same time in ways
that you're more likely to discover the
truth but it's also an illustration of
grand engineering efforts that Humanity
can take on and maybe a lesson that you
could go even
bigger um I I'm really glad you said
that though too because that that's
absolutely true I mean it's it really is
an impressive it's it's impressive in so
many ways it's impressive
technologically it's impressive at
engineering level it's also impressive
that so many countries work together um
to to do this it wasn't just one country
and how it was it was also impressive in
that it was a long-term project that
people committed to and made it happen
so it is a demonstration that when
people set their minds to things and
they commit to it that they can do
something amazing but also in the United
States uh maybe a lesson that
bureaucracy can slow things down to
bureaucracy and and politics politics
and economics many many things can make
them faster and make them slower so
science is the way to make progress
politics is the way to slow that
progress down and here we are well I
don't want to overstate that because
without Politics the you know the L
would happen Nei so um but you need
broccoli
um but sometimes I do think I mean
you're not asking this question but
sometimes I do think when I you know
think about some of these conflicts you
know sometimes it's just good to have a
project that people work on together and
there were some efforts to do that with
in science too to have Palestinians and
Israelis work together project called
Sesame um I think it's not a bad idea
when you can do that um when you can get
you
know sort of for forget the politics and
just focus on some particular project
sometimes that can work some kind of
forcing function some kind of deadline
that gets people to sit in a room
together and you're working on a thing
but as part of that you realize the
common Humanity that you all have the
same concerns the same hopes the same
fears the same that you all human and
that's an accidental side effect of
working together on a thing I that's
absolutely true and it's one of the
reasons CERN was formed actually it was
post World War II and love European
physicists had actually left Europe and
they wanted to see Europeans work
together and and sort of rebuild and and
it worked I mean they they did and it's
true and I often think that that you
know one of the major problems is we
just don't meet enough people so that
everyone think seems like when they seem
like the other it's more easy to forget
their Humanity so I think it it is
important to have these
connections
that